this sunday in los angeles a sellout
crowd is expected at super bowl 56. the
cincinnati bengals will take on the la
rams who are playing in their home
stadium all those spectators and tens of
millions more watching on tv will be
watching a lot more than just football
carter evans reports on a different kind
of show that organizers will put on
before the kickoff
super bowl 56 is set to take off on
sunday
but taking off in the skies above sofi
stadium is history in the making as
different generations of jets
commemorating the 75th anniversary of
the air force were joined together in a
historic flyover during the national
anthem it's got a 40-foot wingspan and
36 feet long this old warbird is steve
hinton's pride and joy it's a mustang
it's like a horse they have different
personalities and what's this one's
personality this is a
this one's a sweetheart she'll be in the
lead during the flyover going at least
300 miles an hour
startup taxi out we'll do a run-up and i
get to hitch a ride on this 1500
horsepower antique
when's the beverage service are you
ready i'm ready
let's do it
that takeoff
within a couple seconds
after that flyby down below fans will be
hoping for a showdown for the ages the
rams haven't won a super bowl since 2000
but back then they were from st louis
this time they're hoping for some home
turf magic led by veteran quarterback
matthew stafford
so many guys have sacrificed so many
things along the way to help us get here
and the bengals haven't been to the
super bowl since 1988
25 year old joe burrow the second year
quarterback grew up watching stafford
play well i always really enjoyed
watching him
i always got to
see him play you know with my family all
around sitting down and watching
football on thanksgiving day
now when it comes to covid everyone has
to show proof of vaccination or negative
covet test to get into the stadium and
once they get inside there will be a
kn-95 mask on every seat but getting
people to wear those masks that might be
a challenge because it passed games here
at sofi thousands openly disregarded the
mask mandate vlad
all right carter thank you very much i
think there'll be some disregard and go
oh absolutely somebody watching the
stands
so carter was on a a a boat yesterday in
a helicopter and now he's in a fighter
jet and a fighter could be on a horse
tomorrow yeah the p51 i mean what a very
persuasive pursuit pursue 51. uh carter
thanks again